IS
SED TO THE SOUND OF
THAT.
WE MADE IT, IT HAS BEEN FUN.
YOU JUST TAPPED INTO THE QUAD
RI
RIDE.
WE'LL HAVE SOME NEW FACES,
BECAUSE WHAT'S UP, NEW YORK,
WELCOME TO HAVING MOBILE SPORTS
BETTING.
WE HAVE SOMETHING SPECIAL PLANS
FOR THE OCCASION IN CELEBRATION
OF BETTING BECOMING LEGAL IN THE
STATE.
DRAFT KINGS HAS FREE BETS FOR
ANYONE THAT SIGNS UP, IF THAT IS
NOT EXCITING FOR YOU, THEY'RE
BOOSTING THE NO SCORE FIRST
DRIVE FOR ALL OF THE FANS
WATCHING THE GAME LATER TODAY.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU ON THE
SHOW, BREG?
HOW ARE WE FEELING, MAN?
WE HAVE TO GET THIS REGULAR
SEASON DONE IF.
>> GOT TO GET IT WRAPPED UP,
IT'S WEEK 18.
THAT FEELS WEIRD TO SAY, BUT
IT'S A NEW REALITY.
FEELING GOOD, A NEW YEAR, GUESS
WHAT?
SAME GREG.
I'M GIVING AWAY HOODIES RIGHT
NOW.
THIS IS THE HANDY DANDY iPAD.
I SEE MIKE RITTER IN THE
COMMENTS.
KNOW
NOAH GOLDBERG SAYS NAJEE ANY
TIME TOUCH DOWN.
>> WE'RE ALWAYS IN THAT GIVING
MOOD.
THAT'S WHY WE ASK YOU FOR THE
ANY TIME TOUCHDOWN SCORERS OF
THE WEEK.
WE WANT TO KNOW WHO ARE THE
LOCKS TO GET IN THE END ZONE.
THESE ARE THE FEATURED CHOICES
WE RECEIVED THIS WEEK.
SCARY TERRI ALL AT PLUS 150 OVER
THERE.
YOUR BOY, GREG, DEEBO SAMUEL
HAVING A MONSTER YEAR.
I LIKE THOSE ODDS ALREADY.
A.J. BROWNE A LITTLE UP AND DOW.
NAJEE HARRIS ONE OF THE BEST
ROOKIES OF THE LEAGUE.
AND JONATHAN TAYLOR ON MARS WITH
THOSE ODDS AT MINUS 300.
I DON'T THINK WE WASTE ANY TIME.
I KNOW YOU HAVE PLENTY TO GIVE
AWAY TODAY.
TELL THEM WHAT IS IN STORE.
>> CONNOR, WE'RE NOT ONLY GIVING
AWAY HOODIES, WE'RE GIVING AWAY
TWO NFL JERSEYS.
ONE TO THE WINNER OF THE LOCK
LEGEND TOURNAMENT, AND ONE TO A
LUCKY COMMENTER LIKE YOURSELF.
DON'T GO ANYWHERE, STAY TAPPED
IN, STAY HERE, GET IN THE
COMMENTS, GIVE US YOUR TAKES, WE
NEED GIFS AND EMOJIS.
WE WANT WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
PLEASE PLEASE PLEASE.
>> THE PLAN IS ASKING NICELY.
LET'S GET INTO IT.
WINNERS ONLY, PLEASE.
WE GOT OUR FIRST CONTESTANT.
HERE.
OF COURSE HE CHOOSES THE SUN
GOD.
HAVING A PHENOMENAL ROOKIE
SEASON.
LOOKING LIKE THE REBUILDING
DETROIT LIONS.
THE TREAT LEGEND, GOING ST.
BROWN, HE HAS A WORTHY
CHALLENGER.
A FAMILIAR FACE OF THE SHOW, AND
GOLDBERG.
AND I HAVE A FEELING HE WILL
HAVE ATLAS WITH HIM.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IF HE CATCHES THIS FRISBEE,
WE'RE PICKING NAJEE HARRIS, IF
HE DROPS IT, A.J. BROWN.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> LOOK AT THAT!
GOOD JOB, ATLAS, LET'S GO NAJEE.
>> ALL RIGHT, ATLAS MAKING HIS
RETURN, SHOWING ATHLETICISM ON
THE QUAD RIGHT THERE.
NAJEE COMING IN AS THE
SELECTION.
WHAT A CATCH THERE.
YOU HAVE TWO ROOKIES HERE
MATCHING UP, THAT MIGHT BE A
SQUAD RIDE FIRST TIME MATCH UP
HERE FOR ST. BROWN AND HARRIS.
THESE TEAMS ARE A DIFFERENT
STORY HERE.
WE WANT TO SEND BIG FAN OUT.
THEY'RE GETTING THINGS GOING,
THEY'RE PLAYING HARD, AND HE HAS
BEEN A BIG PART OF THAT.
>> WHAT I NEED YOU GUYS TO DO IS
GET IN THE COMMENTS AND LET ME
KNOW, AMON-RA ST. BROWN OR NAJEE
HARRIS?
I'M JUMPING IN HERE.
I'M TORN, I'M TORN, WE HAVE
AMON-RA WHO SCORED FOUR OF HIS
LAST FIVE GAMES, HE HAS BECOME
THE NUMBER ONE IN DETROIT, CON
NOR.
HE IS MAKING A STATEMENT AND I
WANT YOU TO HEAR ME ON THIS.
THEY ARE TAKING ON GREEN BAY.
I LIKE THIS ONE FOR AMON-RA.
LET'S TALK ABOUT NAJEE HARRIS AS
WELL.
HE IS COMING OFF OF THE BIG
GAME.
HE WENT 22 FOR 188 IN THE LAST
HE ST THAT COW BELL BACK BACK
FOR THE STEELERS.
ESPECIALLY WITH BEN STRUGGLING
RIGHT NOW.
I LIKE THIS ONE.
I KIND OF LIKE THIS ONE.
IT'S A DIVISION GAME.
THE RAVENS ARE IN AND OUT ON
DEFENSE.
BUT I'M JUST TORN TO MAKE A
DECISION TO I'M GOING TO LEAN ON
THE PEOPLE.
>> IT'S NEVER A BAD IDEA.
THEY GUIDED US THE RIGHT WAY
MULTIPLE TIMES ON THIS.
HE IS HOT AT THE RIGHT TIME.
THE MATCHUP MIGHT BE EXTREMELY
FAVORABLE TO THEM.
HE HAS NOT NEEDED BACK UPS THIS
YEAR, BUT AS WE ALWAYS SALINE ON
THE PLAYERS THAT ARE KEY PIECES
IN BIG GAMES AND THE STEELERS
RIGHT NOW, A DIVISION GAME, AND
THIS IS A BIG BEN ERA AND IT IS
OTHER.
THAT MEANS A LOT OF CHECK DOWNS
TO NAJEE, SO HE WILL GET THAT
WORKLOAD.
WE KNOW BALTIMORE IS REALLY BEAT
UP.
ALWAYS TRUST BIG TIME PLAYERS IN
BIG TIME GAMES.
SO FOR ME IT IS CLOSE.
AND I'M INTRIGUED BY ST. BROWN.,
I'M MORE COMFORTABLE WITH NAJEE
GETTING IN THE END ZONE TODAY.
>> CONNOR IS COMFORTABLE WITH
NAJEE.
LET'S TALK TO THE PEOPLE.
JUSTIN SAYS HE HAS A TERRIBLE
TOWEL.
SHOWTIME OUT TO YOU, JUSTIN,
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODY.
I WANT TO WIN SAYSLY TAKE ST.
BROWN.
THEY WILL TRAIL.
I WANT TO WIN, YOU ARE WALKING
AWAY WITH A HOODY, I'M BACK WE
GO BACK INTO THE COMMENTS.
>> SHOUT YOU'RE WALKING AWAY ON
HOODY.
WE'RE RIDING WITH HAJEE HARRIS
MOVING ON TO THE NEXT ROUND AND
I'M FEELING GOOD ABOUT THAT.
>> ME, TOO.
ROUND TWO, LET'S GET INTO IT, I
HAVE A NEW CHALLENGER I THINK,
BEN MERRICK ENTERING THE FOLD.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> ALL RIGHT, PLUS 120, WE HAVE
TO LIKE THAT.
WE SAID THAT AT THE TOP OF THE
SHOW.
DON'T WORRY ABOUT THAT, GREG
WILL FLIP THOSE ODDS UPSIDE
DOWN.
LET'S GET RIGHT INTO IT, THIS IS
A JUICY MATCHUP HERE AND I'M NOT
JUST SAYING THAT BECAUSE IT IS
FROM THE BREAKFAST LEGEND.
>> LET ME KNOW, IF YOU WANT TO
ROCK WITH DEEBO SAMUEL OR NAJEE
HARRIS.
LET'S CHUMP RIGHT INTO IT.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU SAW THE
INTERVIEW OF AARON DONALD, BUT
HE KNEW WHO DEEBO SAMUELS WAS
BECAUSE THE RAMS KNOW WHO HE IS.
MY GUY HAS BEEN ABSOLUTELY
BALLING THIS YEAR AND HE HAS
TAKEN ON THE RAMS WHO HE
ABSOLUTELY LOVES TO PLAY.
THERE IS A REASON WHY THEY KNOW
WHO HE IS.
HE SCORED IN THE LAST SIX OF HIS
LAST SEVEN GAMES, CONNOR.
NOT ONLY IS HE CATCHING THE
BALL, BUT HE IS RUNNING THE
FOOTBALL FOR THE 49ers.
I LIKE THOSE CHANCES.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT WE DO HERE ON
THE SQUAD RIDE.
I ACTUALLY LIKE THE DEEBO
SAMUELS PLAY.
DO YOU LIKE IT?
DO YOU LOVE IT?
MAYBE, MAYBE SO?
>> I LIKE IT A LOT.
BLETS REAL.
WE'RE GOING TO SEE WHAT THE
BRANDS BRING FORWARD OF COURSE,
BUT IT DOESN'T REALLY MATTER
WHAT HE SAYS.
>> WHEN TEAMS TAKE HIM AWAY
THROUGH THE AIR THEY PUT HIM IN
THE AIR SO YOU LOOK AT THAT, YOU
LOVE THAT, IT IT DOESN'T MAT
WRER IT IS WHO IS PLAYING
QUARTERBACK?
THEY LOVE TO KEEP THAT A MYSTERY
ALL WEEK.
I THINK YOU CAN RELY ON SAMUEL,
AND NOT TO TAKE AWAY FROM HARRIS
AT ALL.
I'M EXCITED, GREG.
DOES THE AUDIENCE SHARE THE SAME
FEELINGS?
LET'S GET INTO IT AND SEE.
>> OH, YEAH, THEY'RE RIDING WITH
DEEBO.
I HAVE BIG RAIL.
SETH DOING THE SAME THING.
SHOUTOUT TO YOU.
I HAVE JRJ TUCK YOUR CHAIN,
WINNERS ONLY PLEASE.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU JRJ.
YOU KNOW THE DEAL.
EVERYONE THAT I MENTION HAS ONE
WORD.
THEY ARE DOING EVERYTHING FOR
SAN FRANCISCO.
EVERYBODY THAT I MENTIONED
YOU'RE ALL WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODY.
THIS MAKES ME HAPPY BECAUSE OF
DEEBO SAMUEL SITTING AT PLUS 120
AGAINST THE RAMS.
SITTING AT PLUS 120 TO SCORE, I
LOVE IT AND HE IS MOVING ON TO
THE NEXT ROUND.
>> HE IS NOT THE SQUAD RIDE
LEADER JUST YET.
AND I THINK WE'LL HAVE TO CALL
UP A FAMILIAR FACE TO CHALLENGE
SOMEONE.
HE HAS SOMETHING EXCITING FOR US
THIS WEEK.
>> WHICH EVER TOY HE PICKS,
THAT'S THE ANY TIME SCORER THAT
HE IS PICKING TOMORROW.
>> ROCKING WITH AJ BROWN ANY
TIME SCORER.
>> MINUS 105.
SO NOT THE BEAUTY OF PLUS MONEY,
BUT YOU TO LOVE THE PICK.
WHEN AJ BROWN IS THE TARGET
MONSTER, THE FOCUS OF THE
OFFENSE, THE GUY GETS THINGS
DONE.
I KNOW YOU LOVE DEEBO.
AND I KNOW ♪YOU ALSO LIKE AJ
BROWN ENOUGH IN THAT OFFENSE.
I THINK THAT MIGHT BE ANOTHER
ONE WHERE WE'RE LEANING THROUGH
THE COMMENTS TO GET US THROUGH
THE FINISH LINE.
>> THIS IS TOUGH CON NOR, I JUMP
IN HERE BUT I LEEK THIS ONE
BECAUSE OF THE MATCHUP.
I LIKE THIS ONE BECAUSE OF THE
MATCHUP.
CONNOR, I STRONGLY BELIEVE MY
GUY RYAN TANNEHILL IS STARTING
TO DEVELOP SOME CHEMISTRY BEFORE
THE PLAYOFFS.
HE WAS FEEDING MY GUY A.J. BROWN
AGAINST THE 49ers.
DEREK HENRY, I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
HAVE SEEN HIM PRACTICING.
HE HAS BEEN COMING BACK IN THE
PLAYOFFS.
I KIND OF LIKE THIS PICK, I KIND
OF LIKE IT, BUT YOU KNOW WHERE
MY HEART LAYS.
BUT TALK TO ME.
WHICH ONE DO YOU LIKE?
WHICH WAY ARE YOU LEANING?
>> I AM THE SALES PITCH.
WHEN HE CAME BACK, HE HAD 16
TARGETS.
SO HE IS THE GUY GUNSHOT WOUND
BEYOND MEASURE FOR ANYONE ELSE.
HE IS AS TRUE OF A RECEIVER AS
YOU CAN FIND.
HE IS NOT BACK YET.
SURE YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBERS
LAST WEEK AGAINST MIAMI.
THEY DIDN'T NEED HIM TO DO MUCH
AND MIAMI HAS THE BEST CORNER
DUO IN THE LEAGUE.
YOU'RE 100% RIGHT ABOUT THE
MATCHUP.
IT'S JUICY AND THEY WANT TO
CLINCH THIS NUMBER ONE SEED.
THIS IS THE HARDEST WEEK TO
FIGURE OUT WHO PLAYS WHO, WHO
WILL REST?
THEY WANT TO CLINCH THE NUMBER
ONE SEED.
AND FOR OUR FINAL SQUAD RIDE.
>> CONNOR, LET ME HOP INTO THE
COMMENTS.
I GOT LOUIS SAYING HE IS BACK,
HE IS HAPPY.
YOU ARE WALKING AWAY WITH A
HOODY.
I HAVE DAK IN HERE.
IF YOU LIKE MONEY, LOCK IN A.J.
BROWN.
CHEWY ION, HE JUST DROPPED THAT
TAKE.
AJ IS FOR WINNERS ONLY.
I'M TRYING TO FIND OUT WHO SAID
THAT, IT'S MIKE.
CONNOR, UNFORTUNATELY, I HAVE AJ
ALL DAY.
AJ ALL DAY.
HOLD ON ONE MORE.
HE IS BACK.
ALL RIGHT, THAT IS ENOUGH.
IT IS AJ BROWN TAKING OVER THE
COMMENTS.
YOU KNOW WHERE MY HEART IS
LEANING, BUT I'M OKAY.
I'M A TEAM PLAYER, I'LL RIDE
WITH THE SQUAD ANY DAY, BUT IT
APPEARS THEY HAVE CHOSEN A.J.
BROWN.
LET ME SHOW YOU SOMETHING SO I
CAN SHOW YOU THE MAGIC THAT WE
DO RIGHT HERE ON THE SQUAD RIDE.
POOF, THERE IT IS, THANKS TO OUR
FRIENDS AT DRAFT KINGS SEND US
YOUR SCREEN SHOTS OF YOUR BETS,
VIDEOS, CELEBRATIONS.
WE WANT WINNERS ONLY.
ALL RIGHT, KEEPING IT MOVING,
WE'RE TILL LOOKING FOR WINNERS
AND WE HAVE THE KMEENT CONTEST,
WHAT RECORD ARE YOU BETTING ON?
AND WE HAVE THE REGULAR SEASON
RECEIVING RECORD.
WHAT ARE THE PEOPLE SENDING YOU
THIS WEEK.
THIS IS TOUGH, WHERE ARE THEY
GOING?
>> TELL ME WHICH ONE, I'M GOING
TO SELZ THEM A HOODY AND I MIGHT
SEND YOU A HOODY.
YOUR BOY, TJ WATT TALKS DOWN THE
SACK RECORD TODAY.
THEY ARE FACING THE RAVENS.
THEY ARE ILLUSIVE CORNER BACKS
OUT THERE.
DO YOU LIKE THIS ONE?
>> I DO LIKE THIS ONE.
I WORRY A LITTLE BIT BECAUSE OF
THE RIVALRY HERE.
DOES HE GET TRIPLE TEAMED HERE
TODAY.
FOR ANYONE THAT THINKS HE NEEDED
THE EXTRA GAME, THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY TRUE.
HE HAS A CHANCE TO DO THIS IN A
VERY NORMAL AMOUNT OF GAMES.
I THINK HE HAS A SHOT.
I LIKE TYLER HUNTLEY'S
ESCAPEABILITY.
IT WOULD BE EXCITING IF IT
HAPPENED TODAY.
IT WOULD BE HARD TO FATHOM.
SINGLE SEASON YARDS.
DO YOU THINK THIS HAPPENS TODAY
TAKING ON THE 49ers?
>
>>.
>> I THINK THAT THEY WON'T PUT
THAT ON COOPER KUPP.
I THINK RIGHT NOW BESIDES THE
FACT -- I'M NOT SURE THEY
NECESSARILY NEED IT, GREG.
THAT'S MY BIGGEST QUESTION NOW.
I KNOW YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO SAY
NOW BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
SEEING YOUR 49ers.
>> I WILL BE HONEST HERE.
I WILL BE HONEST.
I CAN'T SEE THIS POSSIBLY
HAPPENING.
SIMPLY BECAUSE THE 49ers CORNER
BACKS, THEY'RE STRUGGLING THIS
YEAR.
JOSH NORMAN JUST GOT PASSED LAST
THAT IS THEIR CRYPTONITE.
I BELIEVE THERE WILL BE OPENINGS
FOR HIM TO FIND HIM AGAINST THAT
DEFENSE.
I CAN'T SEE COOPER KUPP HAVING A
DAY TODAY.
LET ME GET INTO THESE COMMENTS
TO SEE WHO WE ARE GIVING AWAY
HOODIES TO.
ALL RIGHT, LARRY, COOPER KUPP
LOADING, EASY MONEY.
I LIKE THAT HERE WE GO.
I GOT I WANT TO WIN.
I LIKE COOPER KUPP OVER TJ.
SHOWTIME OUT TO YOU, BROTHER.
THAT IS ALL, MAN, THAT'S IT.
BUT GUESS WHAT, CONNOR, I'M
GOING TO GIVE BOTH OF YOU GUYS
HOODIES, IT'S WEEK 18, MAN, WEEK
18.
>> GIVING SPIRIT HONESTLY, BEING
REAL WITH YOU.
ALL RIGHT, WE'RE GOING TO GIVE
ONE MORE THING AWAY.
LAST BET OF THE REGULAR SEASON,
GREG, LET THEM KNOW WHAT DUO
HERE.
>> IF YOU'RE NEW TO THE SHOW,
JUST MAKE SURE Y'ALL LET US KNOW
IF YOU'RE ROCKING WITH ME OR
CONNOR RIGHT HERE.
JUST LET US KNOW IF YOU'RE
ROCKING WITH ME OR CONNOR, GET
RIGHT TO IT.
WHAT'S YOUR BOLDEST BET?
>> WE MIGHT SEE SOME BAD
FOOTBALL OUT THERE ON THE FIELD
TODAY WHETHER OR NOT PEOPLE ARE
HURT, WHETHER OR NOT THEY WANT
TO GO HOME, THEY WANT TO PLAY
GOLF, OR THEY WANT TO BE IN K
CABO.
AND THEN THE PATRIOTS AND THE
DOLPHINS, I DON'T THINK THEY
WILL DO A LOT AGAINST THE
OPPOSING SECONDARIES.
SO WE'RE GOING FOR VERY LOW
POINT TOTALS.
I'M GOING TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I THINK THIS WILL BE SOME UGLY
FOOTBALL THIS WEEK.
>> I ACTUALLY LIKE THIS.
I'M GOING WITH MY GUY FROM
CLEANING.
MY GUY MAC MAC JONES, YOU
MENTI
MENTIONED THE CORNERBACKS BUT
FEAR NOT.
YOU SAW WHAT THEY DID LAS WEEK.
EVERYBODY SEES THEM AS A GAME
MANAGER, THE GUY THAT IS JUST
HANDING THE BALL OFF, BUT NO.
MY GUY IS GOING TO COME MAKE A
STATEMENT AS TO WHY HE SHOULD BE
ROOKIE OF THE YEAR THIS YEAR.
SO LOOK FOR MAC JONES TO BE
TOSSING SOME TOUCHDOWNS TODAY.
>> ALL RIGHT, TELL THEM, ASK
THEM WHO THEY'RE RIDING WITH
HERE.
WE HAVE TO FIGURE THIS THING
OUT.
WE ALWAYS GIVE AWAY TO ANYONE
WHO IS RIDING WITH ME, RIDING
WITH GREG.
>> GRUMPY PINEAPPLE, MONEY BETS,
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
I GUESS HE IS RIDING WITH BOTH
OF US, CONNOR.
I HAVE J WILL 86.
HE SAYS GET SOME GREG MACK ALL
OF THE WAY.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU, BROTHER.
HERE WE GO, I HAVE WOW,
DEPENDENTS ARE JUMPING.
CONNOR, JT 100 PLUS YARDS.
SHOUT OUT TO YOU.
YOU'RE WALKING AWAY, I DON'T
KNOW WHO THEY'RE CHILDHOODING,
BUT IT IS OKAY.
THEY'RE BOTH WINNERS, THEY'RE
BOTH GOING TO RIDE.
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
SHOUT OUT TO EVERYBODY.
>> THAT IS RIGHT,
CONGRATULATIONS TO THE QUAD RIDE
CONTENDERS AND THE WINNERS.
OF COURSE OUR GUY, GOLDBERG,
THANK YOU FOR EVERYONE IN THE
COMMENT SECTION ESPECIALLY
SHOUTOUT TO EVERYONE THAT WON A
HOODY.
I WOULD USUALLY SAY RIGHT NOW
CATCH YOU SAME TIME SAME PLACE
NEXT WEEK.
BUT WE WILL BE ON SATURDAY AT
2:00 P.M.
SO WE ARE BACK, WE'RE NOT GOING
AWAY FOR THE PLAYOFFS, WE'RE NOT
RESTING, BUT WE WILL CATCH YOU
ON SATURDAY AFTERNOON.
BE WITH US THEN.
ENJOY THE FINAL WEEK OF THE
REGULAR SEASON, EVERYBODY.